[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
insights into structure dynamics and
function of endocytic vesicles on the
stellaris confocal platform
i am marie stone of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica microsystems to learn more
visit leica-microsystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
julio roberti phd product manager
advanced confocal imaging
julia you may now begin your
presentation
hello thank you for joining it's great
for me to be here
today i want to share with you a story
around structure dynamics and function
of intersected vesicles with the
stellaris confocal platform
the vesicles i'm going to focus are here
you see them in this movie they are
these fast traveling um
structures that you see in red
and they are the central players in what
we call the endocytic pathway
we know that these vesicles are not just
swimming inside the cells but they
shallow material by interacting with
multiple organelles and cellular
components and they do it in a very
dynamic way
this dynamic aspect of course is a
common theme of life and using different
life lessons imaging approaches we can
find answers
from a structure going to molecular
mechanisms to reach a mechanistic
understanding and a functional
understanding of a given process
going from molecules
to organelles
to organisms
and
i hope to show you in this presentation
how different tools and modalities
integrated in our stellaris confocal
platform can help you in this quest
across scales
so to give you an outline of my
presentation first
i will focus on the vesicles experiment
and show you how we can image them at
the right speed quality
then i will show you how we can get
functional information from this pathway
using a set of special tools
after that
i will expand into how to build a full
picture from even more angles exploiting
our stellar's platform capabilities and
a brief summary at the end
let's start on how to get the required
speed and quality that we need to study
the trafficking in these vesicles i
showed you
going back to the timeline
that you saw at the beginning we have
here four fluorescence labels in light
cells
we see the actin filaments in magenta we
see microtubules in yellow we can also
observe very clearly the microchondria
in cyan and the same membrane and
internalized vesicles are displayed as i
mentioned in red
we are capturing this information in
high quality and detail enabled by key
components of our confocal
these key components are our next
generation white light laser a full
reworked beam path our spectral
detection concept and the new power id
detector family
our stellaris platform was designed with
the goal of maximizing photon collection
in the mildest conditions to enable
gentle lifestyle imaging
and now
in the next slides i want to go more in
the technology details that enable this
benefits so i will start with the
detection capabilities behind the
stellaris detectors
the power high definition is built on
two main architectures we have the power
ids
that are based on silicon multi-pixel
photon counter technology and
here the fluorescence photons are spread
onto a detection area comprising an
array of independent detectors of units
each one is a silicon avalanche
photodiode which are all wired in
parallel and read out over common anode
around this mppc technology we have
engineered a unique concept to get
superb image quality
we worked on a three-stage calling
scheme to suppress that noise
and on the opto mechanical design to
ensure a maximum photo collection
the power ids can operate in analog and
in photon counting mode and it is our
all-round high-performing detector
it delivers excellent sensitivity in the
blue ring respectful range that is key
for some of the most widespread life
surface and protein attacks and it also
provides a broad overall detection range
that extends out into the nir range so
the near infrared
up to 850 nanometer
i will show you later in the
presentation that this extended range is
great in combination with the excitation
provided by our white light laser
technology
now let's move on to the other
members of the family of detectors on
stellaris
we have the power high dx and the power
high dr
these two detectors are based on hybrid
detector technology so we have here
photocounted from plate that is a
gallium arsenide phosphide for high tx
and extended red gallium arsenide
arsenide phosphide for high dr
and
they are coupled to an avalanche diode
the readout for these detectors is fully
digital and photon counting based with
virtually no dark noise
all the three types of power id
detectors as i mentioned enable photon
counting that is the mode of measuring
signal coming from a sample when one
wants to be
quantitative
and leveraging from the photon counting
properties of our detectors and the
electronics of stellaris we have
introduced power counting
power counting is a proprietary concept
for identifying and counting photons
that otherwise we would miss from our
experiments
so what happens in the photon counting
regime we can detect single photons
and we
will characterize this single photon
detection by a given pulse width
so in principle we can also detect two
photon events separated in time so we
will have the pulse width defining
uh these photon detections and we will
have also a second uh parameter to
characterize that is the pulse pair
resolution that gives us the uh temporal
spacing in the arrival of the of the
photons
so in conventional counting what it can
happen is that uh when we are detecting
photons when we have a second photon
arrival that is below the plus per
resolution then this would this second
photon will be missed from the counting
because it will be
confused and integrated with the first
photon that was detected
with power counting what we can do is
correctly account for the second photon
by using the pulse width information
if we now look at images of different
cellular structures
that were recorded with or without power
counting what we get is an increased
signal and this happened for all the
three types of detectors that we have
for the ids on the high x and for the
high dr
and
we also get an extended dynamic range
while staying and being quantitative
and that means brighter crisper imaging
images and more detail
and talking about quantitation we can
translate the benefits of power counting
by looking at recorded signal as a
function of the
excitation in intensity so what we see
here the power counting is the red solid
curve we see an enhanced dynamic range
compared to conventional counting where
the linear response in conventional
accounting is really at this low
level
we have published a nature methods
application note with the principles and
applications around the power id family
and this application node is open access
and you can find it very easily and we
can share the link with you to go into
the details and learn more
i mentioned earlier that one of the
ingredients to
get great quality images was our new
generation of wildlife bases
so this is the second key innovation
embedded in stellaris that rounds up the
capabilities of the detectors with
optimal excitation maximizing the signal
combined with the aovs acute optic beam
splitter technology we have a system of
ultimate flexibility and less complexity
because we have a single laser can that
can do the work of many
we can uh apply up to eight single
excitation lines simultaneously and we
have a huge and extended
range of uh wavelengths to choose from
in the case of the white light laser
present on the stellaris 5 and the
stellaris stat system we have excitation
capabilities from 488 to 675 nanometer
with an optional nir extension up to 790
nanometers and in the case of the
stellaris eight we can go even from four
forty nanometer excitation up to 790
nanometer
and this means that you can perfectly
match the excitation according to the
404 or the floral force that you want to
use
and a key point
here and a very
interesting one is that the wider laser
range for all members of the stellaris
portfolio can offer excitation as i
mentioned up to the nir range which
offers extra benefits combined with the
nir detection capabilities of the
detectors of the power id detectors
and this allows for example to very
easily realize multi-color experiments
like here
where i can show you five colors
simultaneously with three of them in the
nir range
so this was recorded with celery five
and sterilize five can now deliver at
least three more colors in the nir range
as an example
so with this i have covered the image
quality aspects that we need to address
signal quality and temporal resolution
that we need to study the vesicles in
the context of the cell
so now i want to go into the second part
of my talk and focus on getting
functional information on top
of
the speed
as we know fast processes happen at many
different levels in the cellular
environment and to study them we must be
of course at the right speed but that is
not enough
we also want to learn something and that
comes hand-in-hand with understanding
what's going on and that implies
understanding and getting to
grasp the function of the molecules
and that is why
speed needs a special extra and to show
you this i will go back to the traveling
vesicles although this time i will start
with this time lapse that shows fast
transport in action
one thing i have not mentioned yet is
which labeling we are using here and
uh in this case we have labeled the
cells with an nir membrane fluorescence
probe and we captured the fast vesicle
movements with a speed of one volume
every 1.8 seconds
this kind of experiments are um
typical when one would perform um
studies on endoscopic pathway which is
super relevant to
many different processes like
cell dynamics
signaling growth and also post packaging
interactions that is a very hot topic
nowadays because
many animal viruses enter host cells via
endocytosis
during endocytosis
we have endosome maturation
now a hallmark of endosome maturation is
the ph changes
that
take place as the maturation
is happening going from ph 7
to 4 from the cytosol early late
endosomes and finally reaching
lysosomes
and this is where function comes to play
if we can sense those changes in ph we
can understand what's going on so we
need to find a way not only to visualize
the vesicles but also to get a readout
of the ph changes
and now you can see that the limitation
is not only
and not on the speed but on the sensing
because
if we just
restrict
our
measure and measurement to the photon
counts that we detect
that is the intensity
we don't have a huge revelation of what
is happening about the functional state
of the vesicles because the ph changes
are not reflected here
so here i have a zooming region of
the movie and
we can track the vesicles
of course which we can watch them come
closer even fuse but
that's it
and here is where
we have a very special set of tools that
kick in this extra ingredient i was
talking about
and we have developed these tools
because we know that one aspect of
fluorescence is the intensity but there
is an extra dimension which is the
lifetime dimension and we want to access
that on our confocal and we want to do
that because with lifetime we can sense
environmental changes and that can give
us access to functional information to
characterize in this case endosome
maturation
so
here we go
the first special tool that i want to
show you is tau contrast where we use
the average arrival time of the photons
and that is lifetime based information
to reveal what the vesicles are doing
so now we have the speed and we have the
ph sensing information because the nir
probe that we are using behaves
differently at different ph values and
that is the environmental change that we
are exploiting and mapping as a color
palette together with the intensity that
we already
got from the confocal experiment and
this happens
simultaneously and from the same
measurement that we are
acquiring
and
we can do more
using a second special tool called
tow separation we can interpret the
lifetime direct information in more
detail and we can generate different
channels according to the different
response that the probe sensors from the
different ph values
with some more work this can be
translated into different modulation
steps
and
this is how
mapping of the lifetime dimension looks
like with this extra layer of
information
we can here as we see here we can
overlay the channels and now we see the
vesicles in different colors that
correspond to different functional
states
and now if we go to the zooming region
we can now see the vesicles in different
states traveling and fusing
we already had the speed to follow the
process and now we have added the inside
into the functional state thanks to
these special tools
and as a bonus
as i mentioned because we used and and
our level name and level sorry this
means that we have all the rest of the
spectrum window standard let's say
spectral window free to choose other
labels that are relevant to the
application that one is interested in
investigating and leveraging once again
from the flexibility of the excitation
and detection of stellaris
these tools that i explained how
contrast and tau separation are part of
our new thousands technology in our
stellar school focus again we you can
find
more information on this um technology
on thousands on a nature methods
application note and here is the address
we will share it
with you so you can get more details
so now with this mx plotting example and
with this results coming with functional
insight we can do even more and for that
we will use avia
so i want to highlight in the next
slides
and this extra powerful possibility that
comes with the options available in the
avia software package combined with
these results from the thousands
experiments
so with avia
we are capable of now tracking the
individual vesicles not only at the
intensity based level of information but
indeed using the tau separated channels
in which we have staged the different
maturation levels
here we have this information and we can
analyze it downstream to look for
mechanistic hints of the maturation
process
so what you can see here now is that the
different
channels and the different
steps in maturation so how these tracks
look like
and now for the analysis of the tower
separation separated channels we have
included a large uh number
of tracks uh per channel so you see them
here and we got different metrics
related to
each of these tracks so with this
metrics we can
now put numbers to the behavior of the
vesicles in different functional states
and this could for example serve as
criteria to compare how the process is
affected upon external perturbations
upon stress and integrating uh so
information coming for and for example
from experiments where we address up and
down regulation of single importance
so here what i have selected is the mean
track velocity and what you can see here
is a distribution of this uh parameter
and what we get here
is a hint that there
may be two populations in play and now
this is worth
further investigation down the road
with the rest of the analysis and
integrating a complementary information
finally i want to bring a
final
topic into this presentation and change
gears and enter the last part of my talk
in which i want to
discuss and show you how to build
the full picture from even more angles
and
this brings me back to one of the first
slides
because we have developed our confoco
with the idea in mind that you can find
the answers to your questions with
complementary approaches in a single
system so our confocal is
the tool for addressing your science and
not a bottleneck
and i selected as complementary modality
our latest approach to stead with the
aim of characterizing further the
endocytic vesicles
and
this is inspired by a unique combination
of stead and lifetime in our system and
that is what we call tau stat
and before we go into the application
example of the vesicles i want to
explain why we developed taustead and to
do that i selected
this example on this different
sample
that shows very nicely the essence
behind
our
development
what we have here
um are
nuclear pores immunostained with alexa
455
using an antibody that targets the poor
basket
we expect to get point-like structures
but their sizes are way smaller than the
diffraction limit so we cannot really
resolve them
and if we think of the lifestyle imaging
experiments i have shown so far what we
aim to do
one would like to approach stead in a
very gentle
light dose condition approach so we
apply that idea here in this sample and
for that i just tweaked the
alexa 455 with a tiny bit of steady
light let's say
two percent
in conventional state this is what we uh
get as a result
we can get a bit of improvement to count
the poor units but this is really low
quality and we gain little little
structural detail
and this is how the same image at the
same gentle light dose looks
when we apply and when we use taustead
we protect the sample
we
reach great state quality and we
increase the resolution greatly
this means we can apply thousand to
resolve
the structural details now on
our vesicles going from a confocal
to taos that as you can see here where
we have
vesicles in this case labeled with
cef594
and we also have a second label circulin
that we use to
label the microtubules
we can also apply
this approach dynamically
as you can see here
and in the context of stat resolved uh
microtubules and
we can see here
dynamically
the
traveling and the
dynamics of the vesicles and we have the
possibility of tracking the vesicles and
characterize the motion as they travel
along the cytoskeleton and we have done
that and you can see here in this
gallery
how we can track the movement and assign
and
pinpoint the position of the super
resolved vesicles over time
so i mentioned that tau stat is possible
thanks to the unique stead and lifetime
capabilities of our stellaris system and
the question now uh is why this is so
why is lifetime based information so
powerful
and the answer lies in the heart of the
fluorescence emission process so let's
take a closer look and for that i have
this uh simplified javelin scale and
diagram in which we in which we can see
the excitation and the emission process
when molecules are
excited from the ground state to an
excited state and then they will
uh
[Music]
get rid of this energy that we
have given them through the emission of
a photon when we have fluorescence
and
this emission is characterized by
a number of photos emitted
and we can measure in intensity and this
is what we see with the emissions of
fluorescence but also another
characteristic is the time that it takes
for the molecules to go back to the
ground state and this is
what we assign and what we measure as a
person's lifetime
and
person's lifetime is very powerful if we
have access to this information because
what happens is that person's lifetime
gives feedback for competing processes
so whenever we have an alternative road
to get rid of this excess energy the
fluorescence lifetime will change this
is what happens when we have for example
an environmental change as we have seen
in the example of the indus
endosome maturation but in this case
the competing process is the stead
process the fluorescence lifetime will
change because of the stat process
taking place
so now let's think about what we see
with stead and lifetime imaging when we
do an exten study experiment what we do
is we have
an excitation um
provided by in our case in our system by
a pulsed
white laser excitation and then we
overimpose the stead donut and by
applying this strategy what we generate
is an effective stead psf that in the
intensity domain will look like a
subdiffraction effective
psf
and when we have access to lifetime
based information
the way that we will see this stat psf
is as a tau coded stat psf in which we
can now
map these differences in lifetime based
information as a gradient in the values
associated with the lifetime that we are
measuring
and
so this means that we can map the
behavior of an and the stat effect along
uh the scanning process in our in our
system in our scanning
system
on a pixel by pixel basis
so uh having us access to this lifetime
information reveals relevant information
for steady experiment
and the way to access this lifetime
information has been realized in
different ways in a um
seminal
approach it gave rise to the gated state
approach and
later on we also have early inspire
inspiration by pioneering work
that
was done to
access this level this lifetime level of
information and we have here the
pioneering work of a beach domini and
also work done by other groups in which
we see that using
the phaser flame approach we can map
this different behavior in
in lifetime and in the case of what
happens with stat if we have this
mapping so this uh visualization of the
lifetime
based information
what we have is the uh for the confocal
um
um information we will have a cluster
and or cloud of uh
information
in our uh phasor plot and what we will
have is for the stat process we will
have a stat what we call a stat
trajectory that you see here as this
elongated uh
cluster in which the longer lifetimes
that correspond to the center of uh the
doughnut when we have the maximum um
resolution provided for by the state
approach are
towards this longer lifetimes and then
we go as this dead effect is applied and
up to the crest of the donut we have a
decrease in the lifetime of the floor
force and also of course what we have is
uncorrelated information that is present
in the form of
background
[Music]
noise and uncorrelated signal
and stellaris is equipped
to
have access to lifetime based
information in the form of thousands
in the form of this technology and a set
of tools to address
different aspects as we have seen in the
form of tau contrast tau separation
to study the inducing maturation and the
get the function and insights
on this process but also the same
technology that serves for this purpose
and gives access to lifetime based data
also enables taostat
so how does it work
what we do for a tested experiment is we
scan the sample and we collect fast
lifetime derived information at each
scanning point of the state acquisition
and we send this information to the fpga
at the fpga level what we will do is
identify the step trajectory and
generate an fpga thousand phaser
and we do this
on the fly at the hda so actually
what we will see so we will not see the
phaser because this will be automated
and done
at the system and a key
[Music]
difference with other type of approaches
is that we don't need to get the
comfortable information to get the taos
that
image
and
integrate the lifetime information
for our state
experiment
and as a first third step we will obtain
the thousand image as i mentioned on the
fly and then in an automated way
and with the telstat output we will be
able to
get an image in which we have suppressed
background
based on lifetime readout and this is
thanks to a tool called
background and also we will be able to
increase the image quality
as a signal to noise and resolution and
this is with the second tool called
tower strength
so
our approach to stepped with
lifetime-based information works
on-the-fly and automated and unbiased
the benefits of towstead spread to all
kinds of different samples and i have
some applications to share
with you now
this is an example
of a non-cleared
mouse kidney section in monostain for
two proteins synaptopodin and nephrine
and this is a particularly challenging
challenging sample because the
structures are really really compact and
what we can see here when we go from
confocal to taustead in 2d in in 3d is
that with taus that we can
increase the resolution and the image
quality in 2d and in 3d
with multi-color applications and as is
in this case the localization of the two
different proteins within
the
sample of course we can push the limits
of resolution and we can do it with tau
study 2d
and in 3d so in this case we have
[Music]
here left a technical sample get a bit
of a nominal diameter of 23 nanometer
and we can see that we can really push
the resolution while keeping an
excellent signal
in 2d for the getaway resolution and
assessment of the
diameter and in 3d i have here as an
example the nuclear pores again stained
with a alexa 40555 and you can see in 3d
how the resolution and the signal uh
quality increases
so with towsted we can reach resolutions
better than 30 nanometer 2d and 100
nanometer in 3d of course depending on
the sample and the flow form that we are
using
and finally yes another example of uh
that now applied for gentle imaging what
we see here is a time lapse of over 200
frames that is performed at radio laser
powers for the uh state of 592 so 10
percent and we have imaging at one frame
per second on live act immune green
that has been uh transfected into uh
cells
so we can track and follow the
cytoskeleton dynamics with stat
resolution over time in general
conditions
so
it tells that we protect the sample for
this kind of applications as well
and
as a summary it tells that we can remove
the background using a physical readout
that is the lifetime information on our
sample we can push the resolution
beyond the limits of conventional stat
and we can apply gentle step conditions
for extended imaging so with this
technology we hope to open the door to
new insights into structure and function
furthering information with technical
details on our technology are again in a
natural methods application node that
you can download
as
it is open access
and with this
i've reached the end of my presentation
and before going
to questions i want to close with a
visual summary
we have seen how the lifetime based
tools provided by uh thousands report on
the function of antacidic vesicles and
these tools are also applicable to
different systems for example here to
the dynamics and to identify different
structures in pneumotostella
we have seen how the next generation
wild die laser with aops the spectral
detection and a fully optimized beam
platform new detectors contribute to
excellent quality and to keep up with
the speed of fast dynamic processes
while keeping gentle imaging conditions
i have not gone into this topic because
of lack of time but we also have
embedded tools to increase the insight
and get more even more detail and
extract more information with lightning
with resonant scanner capabilities and
with new tools powered by alia
we have an user interface for intuitive
and easy to set up experiments just
focusing on the sample and on the
fluorophores that are present in the
sample
we have the last x navigator to explore
the sample and get into the details
after ex
exploring it and
getting an overview of uh the sample in
general
and also we have different modalities i
went into details showing you how taos
that can help for light imaging in
general conditions with excellent
resolution and signal to noise and we
also have multi-photon capabilities with
dive we have a full quantitative flim
approach powered by falcon
and we have also light sheet through
dls and we also have
crs options in our system
finally i want to thank you for your
attention i want to thank my colleagues
that have greatly contributed to this
presentation
i'm happy now to answer
your questions and have a great
discussion
thank you
thank you julia for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
so let's get started our first question
is
in the vesicles movies did you acquire
the time lapse once for intensity and
once for the tau contrast option
oh great thank you so much again uh i
hope you can uh still hear me well
um yeah so
um the movies and the information that
we get uh from the intensity and from
the functional insight with the tau
sense tools uh are acquired
simultaneously so when we make a movie
or just
an image and we acquire the data
we detect the photon incoming so so
reaching the detector and for each of
these photos we can account for the
number that we translate in an intensity
at this in at the same time we can
estimate and we can uh get the lifetime
based information by estimating the
arrival of that
photons and the collection of photons so
we can acquire both informations at the
same time so this is something that you
acquired in a single uh time lapse or in
a single acquisition so it's not
sequentially
done so for the same experiment for the
same image you get both information so
the
intensity
information and the lifetime based
okay thank you
next question
what are useful floor fours for the near
range
yes so um this is something that is
becoming very exciting for us to so to
explore and to hear from researchers
what uh they are um looking into and in
the la in the late last years uh there
has been really
a lot of uh if effort and and an
explosion in uh fluorophores that work
really well for the near infrared range
that give you all these extra spectral
possibilities and also it's uh
so minor um
illumination patterns so um for example
uh there so i i showed in the in the
example silicon rhodamine uh 700
uh all the cell bright i saw seven
celebrate 750 770
um alexa floor 790 750 770
um and yeah so
the these fluorophores are very
versatile so some of them are even cell
permeable so you can conduct light cell
experiments uh with this nir probes and
otherwise other ones you just conjugate
them for example for antibodies for
multiple uh
monostaining with high multiplexing uh
approaches a high number of colors
great thank you
next question
how fast is taustead
oh so
um i would say um owing to the fact that
our system is super fast um by design so
we have
very fast detectors and very fast
electronics so the whole dead time of
our system is only 1.5 nanoseconds and
we have very sensitive uh detectors in
all the spectral range we can perform
and we can collect the lifetime
information that we need
very fast so you would not notice a
difference in
in the speed that you need to tune or in
the time that it takes uh you to take a
steady image if you would do it in a
conventional way or in a thousand way so
as i have shown uh we have this uh
time-lapse time-lapse example uh where
we capture this uh entire cell in
what at one frame per second so
it can be
as fast as you need so there are no
limitations to get the lifetime
information necessary to build this uh
phaser uh approach and to automate and
get
the the thousand result
next question
we see that it is possible to
discriminate vesicles at different
stages based on ph
would it be possible to stain the
vesicles
excuse me would it be possible to stain
the vesicles for a specific protein
marker and follow them
yes absolutely so this is something that
would
be would make uh total sense and uh
we have seen uh that this nir marker
that by the way it's uh the cell bright
750
uh it has this uh response to the
changes of ph and if you have the um
corresponding so you can create this
calibration in a way and stage the
different uh
the different uh steps in in maturation
and you could uh add
extra markers in other
ranges so you could also think of doing
some um
cloning and adding some fluorescent
proteins and you could combine and you
can you could acquire the functional
information by uh tracking and
measuring and analyzing the response of
the nir marker and you would be able to
localize the um
so the
protein of your interest and uh yeah and
and conduct uh such an experiment
together with other markers so
absolutely and i i think it would be
super a super exciting
research uh project
all right
thank you next question maybe i'm a bit
confused could we apply taustead to
cryosamples
um
so
i think so i'm not so sure um
[Music]
um
what this
question um goes to
in pre so i don't know maybe we can chat
a bit with uh so with the
person asking
yes yes so um the
people that when they submit their
questions
um you will get an email and you will be
able to
talk more and get more get more of your
information so you can better answer
that question
exactly so yes
right
um is there a database of markers and
labels commonly used recommended in live
staining of various cell types based on
images you've created
um
[Music]
let me
think so um
[Music]
i i'm just thinking of the material that
we have available so we have uh
published quite recently a guide to live
cell imaging on the stellaris platform i
can look for for the link and share it
with you or you can contact
your leica
rep
in your area so in that
guide we have many examples
and the corresponding labels that we
have used so that would be a possibility
also we have in the
presentations or
powerpoint presentations that we share
with you when you're interested in
finding out more about uh our
microscopes we have uh slides where we
go into details for example uh and we
have a nice table with this nir dice so
i would say the best thing is to yeah to
reach out uh to
your a close leica contact could be an
one of our application specialists as
well and uh yeah so of course you have
my email or we can share it here in the
chat later and you can also contact me
and i would be happy to to share that
information with you
thank you
and we will wrap up with that final
question
uh thank you julia do you have any final
comments for our audience
um just that um reach out to us and um
yeah i'm very happy and thankful that
you joined today
well thank you again julia for your time
today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor leica microsystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on demand lab routes will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone and
goodbye
you